[Music]
now recently you released a new product
called masterclass tell us about that
and how you got involved with it I saw
this program acting to play tennis
famous stars doing that and that where
was approached by masterclass I thought
God forbidden to subscribe to share my
noble knowledge will again just that but
my understanding how the game should be
played or more like a game to talk
I think the final product looks quite
entertaining for I was a mediocre player
so ranging from thirteen to eighteen
hundred is it that you will be completed
for players of two thousand strength
that was also a big challenge because
they wanted to cover the audience as big
as possible but naturally speaking to
doing total beginners and and club
players requires the language so having
this range of nearly 500 points I just
have to make sure that they all will be
excited and engage this at the end of
the day it's more like an encouragement
so listen to Gehrig's for learn what can
birthday if you if you learn from this
hours how to make yourself better is
plenty of welcoming for you to improve
because I have computers you have access
to tons of information so I hope that
these these several hours of chess
teaching will encourage thousands and
hundreds of thousands those millions of
people to to play chess actually to
study Shias muscle
you